[Musique]
il est des femmes et des hommes qui
errent à la recherche d'un coup de
chaleur chaleur humaine chaleur physique
parce qu'ils n'ont plus de maison plus
de lui parce que ils ont tous quitté un
jour et que chaque jour la vie les a un
peu plus abandonnés sur les quais sous
les ponts au dessus des bouches de métro
ce sont des silhouettes familières aux
parisiens ces clochards puisqu'il s'agit
d'eux il y en a quelques 3000 à paris et
dans la région parisienne
qui sont ils comment sont ils arrivés à
s'évader d'une société qui leur pèse
comme un vêtement trop étroit alcoolisé
une paresse défaitisme ou ce goût de la
liberté dont ils sont si fiers et qui
peut être deviendra une prison sans
barreau qui les mène avec la maladie et
l'âge plus sûrement vers la fin voilà
sans doute les causes qui les ont
conduits à à faire une sorte d'abandon
de soi est une abdication sans espoir et
accepter leur misère alors pour mieux
les connaître encore pour savoir qui il
était pour la société
est ce que la société pouvait faire pour
eux marie pierre gauthier et guile du
sont allés à leur rencontre à leur
recherche
de jour comme de nuit et en des lieux
les plus divers rites
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
il est en outre à l'heure et pas
malheureux d'avoir une couche c'est marc
ayrault on mange trop ton pote moi je
suis dit tout revendeur dans l'émotion
chez un marchand de mort e boisseuil il
est est ainsi qu il a perdu 15 ans dans
l'année les ont ramenés à gravir le pic
a été ramenée oui ça passe de pareilles
ses travers à 2 en temps réel ce même
patron j'ai eu un accident terrible et
il ya une chose qui est différent quand
même c'est que la société des gens qui
n'ont pas peur quand même
est ce que vous a reproché à la société
au nom d'un joueur pro changera rien
voyez je suis pas honte de vous le dire
quand il s'appellera brigitte bardot je
sais où pierre habite je mens pas c'est
pour vous dire l turbo a maintenant le
16e j'étais un trou et plusieurs fois
pour avoir la magie de bardot
aurélie van lancker nanterre ce très
bien raison plantaire et tous vont ils
voulaient pas aussi longtemps
[Musique]
j
on va vous aider à vous est marié à la
ferme non oui
la croatie a quitté la ola voir leur
charge
vous devez être bien chez vous le
connaissez mes crêpes
robert trouva soir on agit d ma part
merci
non
démontée
[Musique]
j'ai donné vingt ans de ma vie quand
j'étais jeune il ya deux ans je suis
comme ça et j'ai été soigné les malades
alan terre oui madame à l'infirmerie à
la deuxième manche et en aurait fait
soigner les malades
je leur passe et le bassin gelé
nettoyaient et une certaine instruction
lui je ne sais ni lire ni écrire m'enfin
bon certains d'instruction heureusement
que j'ai un moral encore à ce monde si
j'avais mes plus beaux ou de soi
combien de fois l'idée mais j'ai dit non
parce que ma mère a eu trop de mal pour
me demeure que j'en arrive là noms du
piano jus tout ça
le broker et bar chez lui
on a des hauts et des bas dans la nuit
et on ne doit jamais dire fontaine je ne
boirai pas de ton nous aujourd'hui vous
êtes à la hauteur demain vous êtes bien
il faut tomber deux biarrots et devenir
pien bah oui faut pas tomber de haut
pour se faire du mal
et vous croyez lisez-le avis il vaut
mieux être sous terre que sur terre
mieux enfin il faut leur leur travail
parce que vous savez y en a qui en ont
besoin
y'en a qui en ont besoin
[Musique]
il ya la grâce de dieu
et votre volonté soit faite et non pas
la mienne on dit ce que femme veut dieu
veut par fars
est cinglante
l'histoire
jusqu'à toi
m
après 140 francs
quand
70 s 80 s 90 14 14 14 20 14 30
14h34 sonné pour les profondeurs
je voulais vite être sympa malik
commissaire divisionnaire beaudoin vous
savez en matière de clochards nous
sommes un peu des armes et nous sommes
désarmés sur le plan pénal et nous
sommes des armées sur le plan
psychologique sur le plan pénal parce
que la plupart d'entre eux ne répondent
pas aux conditions qui en font des
vagabonds qui pourrait être sanctionné
pénalement
la plupart en une petite retraite une
pension généralement d'anciens
militaires ou d'assistance ou d'une
assistance médicale gratuite quelque
chose comme ça qui fait que sur le plan
pénal ne se sont pas des vagues ne sont
pas complètement dépourvu de ressources
sur le plan psychologique vous le savez
bien et nous n'avons pas à les juger
mais la plupart d'entre eux sont
parfaitement qui récupère à bhl si l'on
arrive de temps à autre à reprendre et à
réintégrer dans la société
l'un d'entre eux mon dieu et c'est une
excellente chose mais c'est extrêmement
rare alors le rôle de la police
municipale n'est ce pas c'est de les
aider de les aider de les assister et en
gros de les protéger de les protéger
d'eux-mêmes
et puis aussi de protéger la population
parisienne des clochards parce que vous
savez très bien et n'est pas agréable
d'avoir dans son voisinage à comprendre
le char c'est très pittoresque peut-être
à l'oeil d'un cinéaste mais peut-être
aussi pour un romancier ça l'est
beaucoup moins pour le voisinage
qu'est ce que nous on nous les obligeons
à venir à nanterre où là ils sont lavés
soigner traiter au moins pendant un jour
un jour et demi
si vous voulez c'est un répit dans leur
misère dans leur malheur
personnellement mais ce commissaire et
en dehors de votre profession que
pensez-vous des clochards
eh bien je dois vous dire que j'ai
débuté comme jeune commissaire
j'étais très jeune j'étais dans un
quartier qui était assez fréquentée par
les clochards puisqu'il s'agissait de
bonnes nouvelles la partie nord des
halles et avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
de bonne volonté
j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai pu pour en
retirer un certain nombre de ce milieu
j'avais pris des contacts avec des
autorités diverses et surtout de bonnes
volontés particulières
je dois vous dire que j'ai parfaitement
échoué et que je n'ai pas souvenance en
avoir tiré un seul vous avez ramassé
qu'on aime clochard aujourd'hui nous en
sommes à une douzaine en général on
avance 25 à 30 par un massage qu'est ce
que c'est en général comme public si je
puis dire ou sauvés il ya des malheureux
évidemment qu'il est certain qu'il
aurait conduit d'abord la boisson dont
une grosse majorité mais là c'est qu'il
ya des on croit toujours que le char ce
sont des gens âgés alors quand même
beaucoup de chance jeunes gens avaient
beaucoup john oui malheureusement
je ne dis pas qu'ils soient y récupère
après société en a qui s'en sorte et on
a beaucoup malheureusement on s'efforce
de garder quelques fruits à nanterre
mais quand ils veulent bien de garder ça
vous déplaît d'être embarqués vous savez
à nanterre comme boisson donc du coup qu
il mange très bien mais y est rude et la
boisson c'est assez limité parce qu'ils
attirent dans la rue les amériques
certaine liberté
dans les amours de france et est
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on services
atteignent 18 heures la première oui au
mur allait mettre trois buts afin
d'engager le monde toi tu ne doit pas
servir qu'à toi mais c'est pas une
situation de manger dehors nous mais
surtout vaste hall 1
quand il faisait bon on va manger dans
l'herbe cavaignac aux bonbons
et puis au couché noir aussi mais oui
souvenez de chaleur alors ça chauffe en
main
mais ça chauffe à la 11è quand il tombe
à l'eau si on a soit rejoué il produit
on est mouillé cherche à vue là j'ai un
peu ça va passer madame tant que les
chambres ont été jusqu'à 2h mois plus en
prime il se sent proche ou en france
évidemment mais maintenant c'est 15 ou
18 cents je ne peux pas me le permet je
pourrais peut-être me le permettent
malheureusement je ne peux rien du tout
alors je serai vite at il sentait en or
apple intel corp qu'est ce que chantait
abbas étaient 600 bombe a coûté pour
l'instant de champlay roses blanches de
dénicheur engagé à revoir
pendant les cours non ça aurait touché
plus tôt et quelquefois devant un petit
restaurant paul apprennent même même
dans les rues alors l'emploi parce que
dans les coûts autres voitures de peyo
d'un retour fin au début que les
chambres où était à ce prix là mais
seulement maintenant il ya beaucoup de
concierge espagnole et des jeunes tout
ça qui ne savent même pas ce qu'on leur
ruche alors je préfère attaquer
carrément la rue je travaillais à pour
toi j'ai 56 ans maintenant et pour
trouver du boulot tu trouves à l'homme
sandwich et stoppera je ne peux pas
mener d'une panthère voisine dont je
m'en fous croyez moi
le malfaiteur est dissipée des prospects
et sauveur quelque chose dans ce goût là
rolex ans parce que vous devrez laisser
reposer ma voix à l'évangile en indoor à
ces symptômes ainsi suffisait à elle
commence à finir à tout ça c'est pas
drôle du tout
en financer tout ça moi je serai
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
progressez fonds de fonds peuvent être
finir comme cobayes pour que vous saurez
si ça peut servir la science pour moi
j'aurais fait quelque chose d'utile dans
la vie quand on cherchait pas moi c'est
que nous sommes demandé ce ne montrent
pas le parle pas évidemment nous par le
nom qui nous ce qu'on m'a donné
bernard l'île de ré les atteste sa bosse
un peu 33 ans du quartier
trente trois ans vous êtes dans ce
quartier
[Musique]
quand je suis
suis pas voulu rester évidemment parce
que je suis un vagabond
un joyeux chien je vois là bas
[Musique]
et pourquoi mais seulement pourquoi
parce que ce [ __ ] de bleu de toi je
fais la diff
je suis une femme s'appelle faire la vie
me sens enfin défunt au lieu-dit
chiffonniers c'est pareil
s'il faut lier ce même jour six foyers
et c'est pas la même chose s'il n'était
pas là bassement ici fonnier s'est ainsi
inclure ce faire sévèrement c'est ici
pour nous a mentionné n'importe quoi
alors il s'est débrouillé pour pouvoir
seulement 6
et moi je raconte n'importe quoi du
moment du monde le jeu s'emballe pas
voilà les deux symboles ville
boire et après ça avance ça vous fait
voir la vie en rose
rien du tout pas du tout c'est pas mon
cas où c'est plus joli mkp ça sonne
mieux que sa venue
ce huitième pas gabon marchands de
bonheur je n'ai eu connaissance
m non mais tu sais les quatre saisons
pour avec la mi temps arrivait à bourg
santé ça va moins des cuillères sa venue
signer un oui franc et moi on en saura
vous musique parce que ya je ne sais pas
si nous aurons lui suit alors la vie
vous savez rien la vie est comme ça la
vie il faut la prendre comme à l'ère pré
programmés cet orage
je vais arrêter à paris mais toujours
les voir la tour eiffel
on va commencer et après je fonce chez
moi donc je pensais que j'ai bien vu la
tour eiffel et les champs-elysées je me
suis retrouvé au champ de mars
occupé à roupiller sur leur sueur avant
et après j'ai été approché j'ai fait
cette année nous fêtons mais j'aurais
fait toison maroc et 80 ans jerry du
tourne d'ailleurs
et pourquoi vous avez laissé tomber tout
ça parce que ça commençait à apprêter le
monde avant c'est pour la question
j'aurais pu les autres rappeurs comme un
âge où le premier mois pour leur messie
c'est fini pour lui
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire d'autres
qu'on n'a pas d'autre sur les genoux
zz chaîne
j'ai j'ai 40 ans alors justement mais je
je vous dis encore une fois c'est la
question plutôt deux aventuriers qui
paye maintenant nous allons même notre
liberté les deux venus qui sont avec moi
c'est la même misère c'est les gars pour
dépression et il préfère couché dans la
pop rock que dans l'ariège vous croyez
que c'est plus libre je suis avec tout
ce qu'il peut y avoir les c
rha nous tiens ça nous dit accompagné
agora comme ça on n'est pas tout seul il
y avait des moments j'ai bien envie de
retourner chez moi
je
[Musique]